das ist wirklich eine absolute
wetterkatastrophen moment in den usa und
während sich der us-präsident mehr von
der globalen erwärmung in die usa
wünscht ist dieser kälteeinbruch mit
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit eine direkte
folge des klimawandels
wie kann das sein ein kälteeinbruch als
folge der weltweiten erwärmung und was
sind die konsequenzen für europa also
wie ist die lage in den usa und in
europa jetzt in science und fiction
herzlich willkommen temperaturen von
knapp minus 40 grad celsius selbst in
new york das liegt auf der höhe der
italienischen hauptstadt rom sind es
minus 20 grad und im sonnenstaat florida
schneit es zum ersten mal seit 30 jahren
einen bomben zyklon zieht über die
ostküste der usa
die folgen sind fatal allein am samstag
mussten 450 flüge gestrichen werden
am donnerstag waren 24 1000 haushalte
ohne strom
und das nur in massachusetts und in
zahlreichen weiteren us-staaten wurde
der notstand ausgerufen es ist eben eine
absolute wetter katastrophe cnn meldet
22 tote es ist absolut verrückt und auch
tragisch und es ist eine direkte folge
des klimawandels mit an sicherheit
grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
verantwortlich für die kaltluft die in
den osten der usa zog ist der polare
jetstream darüber herrscht einigkeit in
der klimaforschung in einer höhe von
rund zehn kilometern zieht der mit rund
200 bis 500 kilometern pro stunde um die
arktis und beeinflusst unser wetter
maßgeblich er schiebt hoch und
tiefdruckgebiete hin und her
und je nachdem wie er verläuft kann er
kaltluft aus der arktis nach süden
transportieren oder auch warmluft aus
dem süden in den norden eine folge des
klimawandels die jetstreams war nämlich
immer stärker nach süden eine folge der
immer wärmeren arktis die den polaren
jetstream schwächt der fängt dadurch an
im wahrsten sinne des wortes herum zu
eiern beulen im stream
die sogenannten rost wie wellen werden
stärker und führen so automatisch zu
wetterextremen und sie bleiben einige
zeit stabil was das wetterchaos noch
verschlimmern sie bringen zurzeit die
kalte polarluft mit viel schnee weiter
in den süden und dann auf dem rückweg
warme luft nach norden zwischen solchen
entgegensetzten luftströmung
kann dann ein bomben zyklon entstehen
der neben den niedrigen temperaturen für
weiteres chaos sorgt zitat seit dem
jahreswechsel sieht man deutlich dass
der jetstream über nordamerika eine
würdige form angenommen hat mit winden
die kalte arktische luft in den
nordosten der usa transportieren so
marlene kretschmer vom potsdam institut
für klimafolgenforschung pik in der zeit
aber auch für europa gilt genau dieses
szenario der zusammenhang mit dem
klimawandel für europa wurde nämlich
inzwischen durch das pk nachgewiesen
die verlangsamung des jetstreams lässt
die winter im nördlichen eurasien kälter
werden so das forschungsergebnis das
gilt genauso auch für die usa ist damals
also auch für die usa kaum von der hand
zu weisen die usa werden mit diesem
wetterphänomenen zu den am stärksten
durch den klimawandel betroffenen
ländern gehören schätzungen sprechen von
schäden im bereich von hunderten
milliarden dollar
die nasa hat jetzt eine karte
veröffentlicht die die
temperaturveränderung in amerika
illustriert gemessen wurden die
bodentemperaturen in den letzten acht
jahren und mit den temperaturen in
diesen tagen verglichen
das erschreckende im nordosten der usa
war es fast überall kälter und im
südwesten überall wärmer und zwar bis zu
15 grad kälter und wärmer es deutet
einiges darauf hin als würden die usa in
zwei temperaturzonen aufgeteilt gehen
der einen werden die sommer so heiß
sodass die vegetation abbrennt und das
wasser ausgeht und der anderen bricht
die infrastruktur in den extremen
wintern zusammen die bewohnbarkeit des
gesamten landes wäre gefährdet ein
absolutes horror-szenario aber nicht
mehr so ganz unwahrscheinlich und was
passiert in europa auch wir müssen uns
auch wetterkatastrophen wie in den usa
einrichten im letzten jahr hat gezeigt
wie eine rossi will einen heftigen sturm
innerhalb kürzester zeit nach
zentraleuropa schiebt und diese rossi
wäre hätte es so ohne den klimawandel
nicht gegeben wir müssen uns also auch
hier auf so einiges gefasst machen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken cw der klimawandel ist
schuld wenn er kein video zu diesem
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann sollten wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergessen ich den
genau auf die glocke und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran